oui
[Musique]
de nouveaux longtemps
oui
[Musique]
le roi d'europe
aujourd'hui cela se passe en cela je me
serais cependant oublié
je connais ce qui met la main dessus
nous on s'est organisé trois ou quatre
le support pour faire si ça se termine
moi
sans plus attendre
soyeux
le zew
les immigrés entassés
le matin
le tenter
en fait tout autant
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
hu et obama
le
[Musique]
encore moins
obama
auj
bottes
non
[Musique]
ah bon
alors
à
je
[Applaudissements]
quand
e
m
[Applaudissements]
le pas
m
alors
le
maintenant
non
la peur de tout
m
à
le
amano
[Applaudissements]
oh
je ne peux pas
[Applaudissements]
à
alors
non
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
à
[Musique]
on
deux trains de la marque the gazette
au nom de tous la croient qu'ils ne sont
pas seuls
ah ah
oh
non
à
[Musique]
oh
quoi
quand
à
non
moi
à côté
on
tous les goûts
bonsoir
aujourd'hui
on est là
[Musique]
le papa mieux
enfin il
enfin
[Musique]
m
le tout est au top
on a été dans le vercors en isère des
blagues droit d'aller les voir j'ai pas
ne pas nous ne pense
[Musique]
m
c'est pour ça que ça
moi
[Musique]
regardez
il faut les faire tourner
je ne peux pas
complètement
à
le canal
[Applaudissements]
norman cameron
il a des côtés je pense que marie pour
la connectivité on va s'organiser
pour lui
à
aulas
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'on fait
enfin
[Applaudissements]
m
ça va
pas
[Musique]
voilà
aulas
or
non
faire
m
un tour
je ne sais pas
le patois
en deux ans
donne
[Applaudissements]
le
à
non
[Musique]
un jeu
après
elle
non
et toi
la queue
comment
pourquoi
à
oh
moi
franchir un ton un peu
m
à
où
[Musique]
le papillon
le parti
[Musique]
le papier le papier
les papiers et les papiers et les pâtes
et papiers et les papiers et les papiers
et les papiers et les papiers et le
papillon et les templiers et les papiers
ont le temps de le battre est le peintre
et le papier et le parti et le parti est
le contenu et les banquiers et les
pompiers et le portier et le papier et
le coin pu faire le papier et les
papilles est elle appropriée et le
portier est le papier l épargne est le
papier et le papier et les crapules et
le papier et de papier et les papilles
et je n'ai papier tenait papier et les
papiers et les papilles et les papilles
les papiers et les papiers et les
plantiers et le contenu
l épopée c'est le contenu et le papier n
ai pas pu la tenter
[Musique]
c'est la seule chose qui m'intéresse aux
caves ou des fuites les bretons fait là
c'est après pour lequel quand c'est pas
possible c'est la de feu on est là pour
magnifique ce n'est pas là pour faire
n'importe quoi aussi c'est clair et
ferme et était là bas dessinant voulait
tous les papiers et les papiers et les
papiers et les pompiers et les papiers
et les papiers n ai pas fait mieux
et en plus l ai pas pu m et papiers et
les papiers et ne pas piller et les
papiers et les papiers n est pas plus
haut niveau et le papier elle est
appuyée en amazone à bord de l'étang
pillées par les banquiers et les
courtiers
[Musique]
sous les combles je me souviens que la
valeur militaire qui doit mettre en
[Musique]
scène un brin train de changer ma c'est
pas beau mais c'est d'ailleurs la
pagaille dans les rangs des tout le
monde est bien mais derrière cela
m'intéressait de macramé devant la radio
militaire
c'est possible on jouera mieux les
opposer la russe s'est inclinée par les
fans heureux c'est qui cette fois j'ai
été très solide il ya des métiers situés
dans la zone euro tout au plus sait
toutefois c'est que cette fois m
seul le derrière
selon plaît maintenant le syndrome
m
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
d'accord
je tiens à faire ce qu'il a fait ne
s'attend pas
on ne peut seul
[Musique]
à
obama
non
un peu
et vous
il ya là
moi
à
holmes
[Applaudissements]
voilà
quand
aucune habitation qu'on laisse emporter
ricoh gens
quant au corps
tous les sens
dgo
et moi
et pas
oh
oui
heures
ap
il posera
m
samedi d'affaires
le corps
coke encore non
padilha les uns servent tous les sans
papiers
la part le sable se
réponse en jeu
le pape en a
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
et vous
étouffés égalité vous pouvez y arriver
non non non
non
pourquoi
ô toi
alors
ils en ont
la commune
achat
maman
oh là là bas
pourquoi
immigrer aux avocats un billet avant
sakho
qu'est-ce qu'on est tombé à lutter pour
l'égalité
[Musique]
et toi
les propos de maman
non
la maman
nous on
devant
tout n'est pas tout
mais quand on
pour moi
deux mamans
pour eux
vous
le moment
oh
non non non
la maman
quand même
m
ans
le haut
demain
la leur
la bonne
un peu
rien
le nouvel an avant impôts
le son
- co
le temps
on avait plus
ma
on a le blues il ya un moment il y en a
marre et leurs habitants
pas
mais bon
maman maman
à panama
pas bien et on peut
à
ça
le bon sens pas dangereux
comme cela
trois patrouilleurs
nous nous sommes plongés
mieux
nous ont pas
e
quant aux
nous sommes pas
je ne sais pas
abo
ne pas
j'avais entendu
nous on ne sait pas et l'on entend le
lait sans papiers dans le jeu
uniqlo un enjeu
[Applaudissements]
déjà
adam je parle de ma france
avant je vois qu'avant ça
informés
encore
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
oh
[Musique]
à
m
on
[Musique]
[Musique]
peu importe
pantalon bouffant 2
[Musique]
oh
m
donc pour nous
tél
en tout dix ans
bon
quand je joue
oh
ces points
papa
[Musique]
paris
m
pourquoi
[Musique]
non
l'eau
[Musique]
e
ça
[Musique]
il y a
d'accord
voir
le corps
tél
non
[Musique]
ça
bon
mais qui
et
à
vous verrez que ce côté cependant vous
devrez s'était rien passé autrement
non on pousse toi si on demande
on
en vain en restant bougent pas
un point est
on nous entoure
nous pensons à tous les sans-papiers
naissance à la cour
[Musique]
angus pas ici nous est plus jeune et je
vais pas démissionner on les a mal à la
pression des phrases qui détruisent les
spéculations un livre est à l'aise pour
tous et pour tous un souvenir
désintéressé et on ne pleure devant nous
est restée bienvenue et à tes côtés ya
des points soit il et la liberté quand
tu vois la main il avoit sécurité
qualifiée pour faire bref voilà très
méfiant paris
la voix c'est une liberté qualité pas
tous le même temps les commissions voire
plus et nous envoyer leur première
partie de ses vols intérieurs indien
côté pile et où la liberté ou la qualité
ou la dentelle
[Applaudissements]
c'est que quand nous nous sommes assis
pendant la crise 12h20 la rue quand la
ville avait l'habitude de critiquer sans
lui mais c'est un terme à l'un des
permis de la ville
un seul banquier jusqu'à maintenant sur
les percées même s'ils laissent percer
ses recettes c'est pour moi mais vous
êtes bien c'est bonnet blanc
on voit internet monaco mais dans les
tribunes
tout y passe connais tu nourris une fois
qu'ils sont oubliés
on va vous laisser traîner à l'appui
d'un mix bien plus bienvenu caisse à la
location de leurs atours il apparaît
s'appelle revenir comme ça tu as la
dernière fois n'a pas eu beaucoup de
place demain ils vont venir vous à la
foule à tout mais ça frise à soignies la
volt ou l'autre si tu ne me plains pas
l'étude fait tout bien tellement
nicollin il vaut mieux et à la rue parce
qu'on a d'elle après qu'un puissant
philosophie des soldats d'afrique
je voulais faire comme celui tout à
l'heure j'ai la peau qu'elle a le même
goût ça continue à ne rien toucher cette
fleur
il est ainsi parce que c'est beaucoup
plus rare c'est parti à caraquet si vous
venez de me forcer à pour construisit
d'amérique
selon the new moon est en chantier
on attend les autres on n'a pas mis à
hurler le consentement de la france
l'augmentation de l'abattement
on connaissait la prise en otage de ce
travail c'est trop cette fois ci les
positions cette page vous pouvez le
vérifier il force est allé voir mon
patron joseph vous êtes un volume comme
s'il attendait les enfants et un médecin
ont avoué sans fard et maman si l'église
est d'arrêter ces 16 ans c'est possible
la loire est prêt à tout mais ce à tous
les français je sais que l'amérique ne
dérange d'abord nous mettrions yammer la
langue est la bise à ces sources elle
est moins dense a permis que le spw
12h15 suis tu sais pas si ce sont les
mêmes chez moi même tout naturel à la
terre avant nous si aujourd'hui nos
vieux dès la 5 master 1 m1 comme ça
comme un mec n'était troisième quart
temps avec seulement plus et la ville
dany cottenie merci beaucoup
le temps dira
tous ceux qui sont ici sont derrière
presque toujours ma part pas forcément
du smic annuel cette fois c'est la
formation la raison pour laquelle on est
arrêté alors c'était les foetus et sans
papiers et exige qu'il n'y a pas de faux
policiers sur les peurs de la
manifestation
la balle du ko prison
apparu s'est justement potier
c'est pas toi du policier autour de 12
quand on est là en exigeant que les
choses de plus sur les côtés
qui sait peut-être est-ce qu'on puisse
pas nous fait c'est en tout cas cette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
année nous les simples et nous sommes là
et ça nous était cité
donc les camarades on s'est concerté s'y
enracinent à on voit pas l'utilité de
venir ici pour faire du manipulé et à
des gens qui habitent près de trois
heures
aujourd'hui 29 ans pour nous l'essentiel
c'est de continuer la même façon
à 20h la manif c'est fini on insère
l'essentiel du fespaco trois offres
d'aller dans les enfants tient de la
préfecture qui furent continue notre
manu voilà
quand je bois plus judiciaire
voilà la parole aux sans papiers
si vous décidez de confiner la manif on
à côté si vous considérez un séjour à
bien la manière sera tous merci
elle voudrait épouser parfaitement
l'histoire
mais les bleus ne sont pas plus mortelle
ça va plaire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
le centre l'est et les papiers mais le
papier papier papier et papiers les
papiers et les papiers et les papiers et
les papiers et les papiers et les
les papiers et le quartier est le papier
et le carton et le papier et le permet
elle est partie et le papier et le
papier et les papiers et les tapis et
les papiers le papier n'est pas plus et
le papier les papiers et le papier et le
parti
le quartier est le parti et le papier et
le papier et papiers et le papier et le
papier l étendue et c'est le papier et
le trafic et le papier et le papier et
les papiers et les papiers et parmi
elles trois pieds et les papiers et les
papiers et les papiers et les papiers et
le papier et les papilles et les
papilles et est le papier le papier de
papier lé papier le papier papier
les pompiers ne peut plus le profil est
le papier sur le papier l épopée et ne
pas piller et les papiers et les
pommiers
elle est en plus je n'ai pas pu et le
papier le papier allait faire mieux
le conflit au plus bas
les papilles et les papiers et les
papiers à copier les kabyles lé papier
les papiers
et puis
[Musique]
copé
[Applaudissements]
merci
cela fait surtout
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
m
dans les changes et qui peut changer
changer
nous laissant parler des gimmicks il
faut il a vu la remise à ses côtés
[Applaudissements]
mais pas de tous les sans papiers de
tous les employés de tout est importé
encore
mathieu
à voir
mieux
omar
[Applaudissements]
sans papiers collés à poitiers 70
vigueur en france
et
olano monde voilà
je ne sais pas du tout ce n'est pas
gênant du tout et je dis moi je te fuis
moi je te fait peur j'ai tout ce n'est
pas je te suis pas j'ai testé par je ne
sais pas jusqu'au port ont fait de ce
départ j'ai du style pas je te ce n'est
pas je ne suis pas fou je dis ça je ne
sais pas
[Musique]
alléchés par les bandits cie direct et
intégré à bing petacchi à la mairie la
compagnie vol à main armée police au
paradis
[Musique]
et à
un show solidarité avec des sans papiers
so so solidarité avec les sans-papiers
sos solidarité avec les sans-papiers
pechos1 solidarité avec les sans faute
et salinité avec nous
avec des sans papiers et so so
solidarité avec les sans-papiers et son
solidarité avec des 58
ok
solidarité avec les sans-papiers face au
solide alif à le quitter sans papiers et
so solidarité avec les inventer seul
saut la solidarité
et avec des sans papiers sol
solidarité avec les sans-papiers leur
solidarité avec des à papier c'est
en solidarité avec d apporter chez so
solidarité avec les sans-papiers
pinceaux
so solidarité avec les sans-papiers se
sont solidarisés avec des amap et chose
solidarité avec les sans-papiers est-ce
aux solidarités avec des à poitiers solo
saut et sol idéalités avec des apartés
façon
le soient solides avec des impacts et
sochaux solidarité avec des saintes
maries sauce au pesto d'égalité avec des
sympathies solo show et solidarité avec
des apprentis et son os os est sous
dialyse a demandé à partir sauf qu'aux
un solide alibi
avec ce papier so so solidarité avec les
sans-papiers sauge et solidarité avec
nos sympathies so so solidarité
[Musique]
béthune et sa beauté et sa beauté
dix ans de l'état seront régularisés
servir dé tous les sans papiers
nous sommes tous les peuples et
régularisation de tous les sans papiers
l'autorisation de papier alu conviés
[Musique]
ap
s'ils pouvaient pas lui la tête voulait
pas lui at elle dit à la presse
merci à lui appelé allemagne et paris
appellent tout aller à paris ap
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
les motos
tous les regards
le bon coup vous connaissez tous les
mois ou tous les mois la police
[Musique]
mais bon
là
filet
il est
dans la ville
avant
maman
on ne peut pas
[Musique]
le
rama
pas
non
oh
[Musique]
on
l'important est le moment
non
m
là
non
la fin
ne nous ont pas
sans papiers entente nous sommes pas
nous on s'attendait
le matin nous sommes pas très palpitant
nous sommes pas cadré
certains soient pas tentés
on en parle mieux nous sommes agressées
par six ne nous sommes pas quand même
nous sommes partenaires
par contre toujours pas tant m
nous sommes pas contents
et tout cela
nous sommes attachés
nous sommes toujours engagés nous sommes
pas
on ne sait pas
allez vous en paca
ne vous attendez
ne touchant pas tavernier
quoi
sympa
on ne sent pas
nous sommes en jeu
à
ou pas
faisant plus doux son patin
on s'en veut
cent pas
on ne sent pas d'enjeu
nous croyons encore tout son poids
bon sens
nous sommes pas dangereux
tous on fera un jour
je
son papa
m
soit pas
on s'en fout
ça va
bon sang froid
pourquoi
pas
et pourtant
et
enfin
[Musique]
le pour toi
voir
[Musique]
non
ah ah
posez votre pension
[Musique]
l'assaut
oh
revers de 3-2 face aux as
de l'autre
[Musique]
mais vers le jeu l'opération
vingt deux heures quand je fais un saut
en
boehner je ne pouvais le faire
notre site
m
là
où
[Musique]
je cours
un peu court
nous
il a peur pour nos enfants
m
ces panneaux
alors
[Musique]
la nation
attention
t'as vu
non
oh
m
à voir
je suis
non
m
enfin
ouais
bush
champion en double
m
arrêté
avec un tamis
mais non
j'aimais jouer
jean
m
[Musique]
claire
là
portrait
[Musique]
après
m
et si celle ci reste à sg suis-je le
temps enfin elle les 6 2
je suis
eh oui
m
[Musique]
on
oui
marty
les
et
à
allez
ah oui
tous
allez pas vous
salut tout
[Musique]
tous
à
hamas et fatah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi pas
non
[Musique]
le papier
m
d'après vous
demain
exemple
a demandé la défense
pour autant pas
il
le
[Musique]
dans l'est
mais silence
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
dix mois
m
cette fois
à
[Applaudissements]
les tonga
tous les combats
correa
ap
m
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous
je vais
oui mais
non
oh
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le monde
si vous passez par l'institut
augmenter
allez
oui
fêtant ses machines ip
[Musique]
tous
mais bon
oui
avoir deux
pourquoi
l'argentine je me suis tenu les
argentins
je
mon 3g
voilà
rudd
à
mais non
et c'est pour une raison
[Musique]
voilà
j'avais avant
les
m
les patrons
alors quoi
ballack
là
[Musique]
il
je suis moi tranquille
[Musique]
vas-y
c
tous
oui
[Musique]
chapelet
oui
savez vous
le tabac
[Musique]
rang
ok
mais l'amitié
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est très bon
à
[Musique]
la bave français
pourquoi
ça sert à quoi
[Musique]
pourtant
je pense pas que les ben laden
ouais
née à six rapports
m
[Musique]
un problème pas canal
parce que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
ouais
je
oui ça rigole que
wen
[Musique]
un téléphone qui verra qui décroche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
votre avis
[Musique]
ce produit
non
j'aime
regarde
je
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
- création du répertoire s'il vous plaît
allez les freinages sur les toits
si les 29 ans et un père mais faire
l'objet d'une verbalisation
on fait un bond
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
manon
support
aller décrocher
en mai
[Musique]